this uh tweet helps you understand why
it is that companies like Chick-fil-A
get woke he says this is serious Anthony
bass is a professing Christian he shared
a post supporting the target boycott now
he's apologizing for hurting the pride
community and he says he'll better
educate himself he is betraying Jesus
and his conscience pray for him I want
to play for you this short clip of what
he had to say here we go I recognized
yesterday I made a post that was hurtful
to the pride Community which includes
friends of mine and close family members
of mine and I am truly sorry for that
um I just spoke with my teammates to and
shared with him my actions yesterday I
apologize with them
and as right now I'm using the Blue Jays
resources to better educate myself to
make better decisions moving forward
the ballpark is for everybody we include
all fans at the Ballpark and we want to
welcome everybody that's all I have to
say thank you oh my goodness so this is
him saying he's going to get re-educated
like no no joke he says he's using the
resource of the Blue Jays to better
educate himself it's literally like we
used to make fun of this you know uh in
The Simpsons they get re-neducated
that's right the idea of being forced to
undergo a struggle session under
education we knew in this country was a
sign something was wrong but look this
pathetic Coward of a man yes like this
has hit in hand pathetic and that's back
to what I was talking about with the
caving conservatives tend to Cave yeah
this guy's how do you feel Sheamus he's
a he's a Christian
yeah I think he should have stayed
strong to his values as a Christian I
mean I don't know what to say I would I
would say he's not a Christian well I
can't I can't say he's not a Christian
but I can say that I don't think a
Christian should cave into a mob that's
trying to promote
sinators who look up to him he's not a
Christian when I was a little kid I
remember uh I went to Catholic school
and and I remember we were learning
about religious wars and stuff like that
in a very limited sense but I remember
hearing about like
you know one religious faction would say
convert or else and then I always
thought to myself I was like why not
just lie just saying oh sure sure of
course I I hereby convert so they don't
kill you well that people would say with
them no they would say no exactly the
fact that this guy
in in what a day dropped to his knees
and begged bed please I'll renounce my
entire faith if you just leave me alone
like dude his balls must have shrunk
down to the size of marbles and sucked
up right into his body three times
before the rooster crowd he denied
Christ from the way I heard that yeah I
mean I'll mention this when you say that
people would say convert or die and some
people would lie about that I mean in
part that's when you ask like why not
lie well they're okay with you lying
they're okay with you not actually yeah
to throw your beliefs under the bus so I
I definitely hear what you're saying
there they want you to profess to the
world that you give up yes and I think
it's very sad that he did this and I
really hope that he repents hope he
repents and turns back to Christ but he
did he's gonna like make a specific
Claim about he was due to make three
million in 2023. so that's what he's
he's speaking for the three million
profits a man nothing to give his soul
and gain the world in return you think
that he would have been better if he if
he just stuck to his word and got fired
amen yeah absolutely you know what's you
know what because they're persecuting
him for the sake of the king him he
should embrace it right what's what is
it it's easier to fit a camel through
the island it's easier for a camel to
pass the I have a needle then for a rich
man enter the kingdom of heaven and
that's exactly but With God all things
are possible that said yes this is
exactly that is one of the reasons
because this guy
it's it's remarkable but but this says
to me this man is not a Christian for if
he truly believed there is nothing on
God's green earth that would have him
profess to the world of rejection of of
of his faith unless he did not have it
in the first place I mean it's hard it's
also really difficult to speak to
whether someone had it in the first
place too those aren't claims I could
make but I would say that was not the
Christian thing to do to renounce but
look my point is this do you think this
man truly believes that when he dies he
will be judged uh that action certainly
doesn't indicate that he believes that I
can't tell you what he does but the
action doesn't indicate he believes he
doesn't believe he'll be judged he
believes that right now in his life he
can say anything for any personal gain
if he he is a fake Christian and this is
this is an issue so many people on the
left have had with Christians for a long
time people like him who claim to be
Christians who clearly are not well no
they love Christians who are willing to
Cave into them right but but no I I get
what you're saying he's very valuable To
the Left Right for Me growing up so much
of the complaints I heard in cities with
that there were people who were claimed
to be Christian and then they would be
the nastiest most Cutthroat evil greedy
people you've ever met and that's
exactly what that guy Christians give
Christians a bad name off yeah and I
have a an example that's interesting I
haven't really told this so we
originally we originally started with
this beer and we announced it we had
worked with a brewery in Illinois and
they had told us initially I don't think
they understood how big this would get
and so initially they said yes they
would Brew the beer for us yada yada but
things were proceeding forward and they
let us know that they're very good
Christians
that they are concerned about what's
happening with all the trans stuff being
pushed on kids they're conservatives
these are things that are important to
them they believed well they believed up
until Newsweek called oh
and then
they they what's the name of the brewery
I pulled that out to make sure I did
because there's another Brewery with a
similar name I wanted to make sure I
have not listed this on anything yet so
I'm giving it to you now the correct one
it is Bent River Brewing Company
and Rock Island Illinois they were
afraid of backlash from the woke mobs
because our can I don't have it right
side up has the word conservative on it
um and they bailed on us so that's part
of it so we're we're our beer is
shipping 30 days out oh I mean if you
they put out to the media that you know
as soon as they saw our ad they they
disassociated with us that you know more
or less we're terrible people they love
everybody but there are big strong
Christians that cared about trans
ideology being pushed on kids in private
conversation and they lied they said
that they stopped working with us as
soon as they saw our ad I've got email
communication with them after so they're
scumbags and they did it under their
giant Christian name
um which is not surprising I understand
I'm making your point here with these
individuals and it is I was I was Zero
bit shocked when it happened because
that's what I come to expect from these
kind of individuals unfortunately we
found other breweries now we've got a
huge Brewery in Florida as well
how many True Believers do you think
there really are on the left
they're cognizant of their ideologies
and their methods I think it's a very
small percentage I think most of them
are just going along and getting along
and that's true of Christians as well
that's beautiful yeah yeah so when
people live in an area that's mostly
Christian they say oh of course we are
exactly then the moment the left call
say sure we're left now the golden get
along people I mean this is what people
say when they point out that if you
lived in Nazi Germany you probably would
not have been on the right ambassadors
would have turned them over in a
freaking heartbeat in a heartbeat yeah
like they can't even stand up to saying
yeah in a heartbeat they can't handle
pressure from you got some nasty email
comments or Facebook comments because
someone wants to cut dicks off kids and
your support you're making a beer for a
guy that says yeah maybe we shouldn't do
that if you can't stand up to that I I
don't I don't think you would have done
too well with the whole Germany
situation yeah yeah amen I mean there
are too many Christians who are willing
to sell out their faith and we don't
need more scared I'm gonna get a lot of
crap for this but I've said this for
years is the Evangelical Community there
there's a part of that they're out there
voting in the primaries and they're
they're hardcore but the general
Christian Community as a whole they
preach something on Sunday but they are
the ones that cave they're some of the
absolute weakest individuals when it
comes to this and I'm probably going to
get canceled for like the 48th Time by
saying this but they continue to cave
and that's again kind of
what this beer is about what we're doing
is it's encouraging people we don't have
to cave and I think the whole Bud Light
effect that you're talking about it's
conservatives are for the first time I
feel like you know you're using Target
as it as the example for the first time
I feel like conservatives are like wow
we have this power like what's this new
power let's try it out this is
interesting because I don't think they
really believed they had it prior to Bud
Light well I think that's what sold it
to them yeah I think that's true and
there's another element I'll add here
which is that we got to remember that
when it comes to Bud Light Target as
well but more so Bud Light there are
easily accessible competitors a person
doesn't really have to make many
significant changes in their life to
just buy a different brand of beer and
so that's why conservatives have to
realize that those in the movement who
would consider themselves leaders who
are go-getters have to start businesses
so that there are competing brands with
uh the big guys so that when people do
have to boycott these companies they
have somewhere else to go
man because if Bud Light was the only
beer brand available I think things
would have gone differently right people
had other options it's good that we did
we need to start creating more options
Matt you think that I think that gree is
greed a sin is great so but one of the
seven deadly but getting rich is not no
getting rich is not necessary you can be
a rich Christian you know they say you
can't take your wealth with you people
that seek and grow familial wealth now
you can do a lot of good things with
money exactly you you can there's a a
rich Christian surely has to live
differently than a rich Pagan right a
rich Christian has to do more with their
money to support the church to support
the poor to help others and you know
even us has done a lot for this country
with his wealth and honestly here's
here's something I should truly thank
Elon Musk this beer company would not
exist without Elon Musk and I can say
that confidently because there's you
know we got roughly over 45 million
views on my Twitter of that ad that
would have never been allowed to happen
in the past under previous ownership and
it's also why we didn't get near those
kind of views on Facebook or Instagram
or anything you know they got a lot of
views comparatively speaking but nothing
like it did on Twitter now that Elon is
kind of taken the chains off it feels
like oh sorry the Christ is like blowing
up through Elon like it's bubbling it in
him like that Christ energy the the
anointed like he's been I don't know if
he's been anointed by God what if that
even means really but like he's carrying
the torch like he's doing things that
will make Humanity better off through
American ideals and I don't know what
better Christian thing you could do in
the Modern Age it's an interesting point
I think I I wouldn't uh describe it that
way theologically however I do believe
the truth is a person and that person is
Jesus Christ so when somebody is
forwarding truth they are doing
something for God in a sense right like
they're they're on the right side dude I
really not in totality but you know
maybe not with everything they do but in
no one particularly everything yeah yeah
yeah but but yeah so dude my point isn't
like any time anyone does something good
they are now a professing Christian it's
just to say that if you're fighting for
truth then that is a service what you
guys are saying Tim what you brought up
earlier I think there are so many people
that identify as Christians that aren't
and so many people that identify as
Jewish that aren't just because they
don't believe in God if you don't
believe like truly believe it because I
don't know if you have to experience it
to believe that it's there but like I
want we'll say there's like 300 million
Christians and probably like point zero
zero zero zero one percent of them
actually are Christian there's there's
uh 2.2 uh billion Christians worldwide
and like probably like a hundred
thousand of them that are actually
christ-like like like yeah but you gotta
remember I mean you don't join the
church for the other Christians you join
the church for Christ because other
Christians are are gonna sin they're
gonna be vicious they're gonna fail to
live up to what they should live up to
but so will you so will all of us right
it's important to keep each other honest
like without consuming ourselves uh to
to be like yo yo like you can talk a lot
of smack about what that guy's doing
wrong but if you're not living that
lifestyle of Christ
this is what the love gets right
wielding power you win yep the
conservatives the right don't that's
what I think the I feel like the Romans
when they set up Catholicism they made
it so that it did not set up Catholicism
that's not yeah that's how it goes you
don't think so it wasn't at the Council
of nicaea 70 years after Christ's death
they no no no no so the Council of an
Ikea uh was a bit after that and this
was not um this was not set up like yes
there was Roman involvement but this is
not something the Romans ran this was
the early Christians basically making a
number of statements about their beliefs
because they're like after the time like
at the time of Christ there were just a
lot of grifters who were coming in and
making up things that had nothing to do
with Christ's teaching so then the
church had to sort this out and go like
okay what is the actual official Canon
gonna be what's going to be in the Bible
like how are we going to
um declare our faith that type of thing
but it was not the Romans who said what
concerns me is the authority of a time
that was setting it up made it seem that
like weakness is key like in order to be
a Christian you have to be weak you have
to be subservient to the authority and
like no man power does control the world
that's what you're saying Tim like the
left has understood this the power leads
and we need that in Christianity well
because the so Christians had been
persecuted for a good while before the
Council of nicer right because this is
yeah yeah this is in the 300 so this is
not like it is after Christ
well no the one that well we'll have an
education on a different show yeah yeah
I guess my point is just that the Romans
did not set up Catholicism but continue
with the point that you were making that
power controls everything yeah is
unafraid and they're ethos and their
moral framework is there is no truth but
power and the right is like let's all
just be good stewards yeah because Jesus
was like all right if you want to kill
me go ahead and then they killed him and
it's like no that's not what you're
supposed to do
memorization well he was like at all
they came and got him and he just was
like no don't stop let them talk about
you stop Shifting the conversation into
arguments I'm telling you why power is
what control like but you keep shifting
it into a way that you know is going to
intentionally insult Christians no no no
but I think the reason why the right
doesn't understand that the value of
power is because Christianity has been
sold to us as if being a surf okay is
wrong is wrong no no what you're saying
is not correct
both Sheamus and Sergeant I mean those
not correct and so I said let's have an
educational conference and religion
somewhere else and get back to the
conversation about the moral framework
of the left let's move on from yeah Mao
figured it out power is what controls
Society out of the barrel of a gun I
think Mouse said and uh unless these
religious folks start to understand that
I'm afraid that there will always be
coming in second well I think that truth
is more important than power and that's
the message here truth is far more
important than power it's better to have
the truth on your side than to have
power on yourself but who controls the
truth is who owns the media no the the
people that there's a reason we call
them Liars instead of saying well the
media said it so it's true
uh yeah but if you don't know they're
lying then you think it's truth and then
you define it as truth you can think
something is true but be wrong about
that
this is the this is the point with the
left
the True Believers don't care if they're
correct they say two plus two equals
five
they've they've entertained that
Prospect because when you come out and
agree with them they know they own you
if if it's it's the Star Trek how many
lights are there
there you're mistaken there are five
likes right they come to you and say
what's two plus two you say four they
say no you're wrong it's five now say it
again what's two plus two they wanna
force you to say the lie I've been
saying this for years they want to force
you say lie I refuse to say the LIE
regardless of the topic whether it's how
many genders whatever it is they just
just say it's a disagree and people who
would rather die than go along with the
LIE are the biggest threat to the
establishment possible which is why they
end up being executed in tyrannical
regime thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time